hey guys Tim Farriss here before we jump
into this episode I'm gonna do something
I very rarely do and that is to make a
direct ask with hat in hand my brand-new
book just came out today it is called
tribe of mentors subtitle short life
advice from the best in the world if you
like the podcast you will love this book
I reached out to a hundred and thirty
people who are the best at what they do
in sports investing business acting
directing you name it we got it
cryptocurrency done and it turned out
better than I ever could have expected
many of my friends think of all my books
it is the easiest to read the easiest to
use so check it out please take a look I
put out so much free material the
podcast is free the 700-plus blog posts
are free every once in a while I put out
something like this
and it's not that expensive so please
take a look tribe of mentors dot-com and
it does make a great holiday gift or
gift for others there's something for
everybody in here it is really a
choose-your-own-adventure guide a buffet
of options for improving your life both
in business and in the personal sphere
so take a look I appreciate you taking a
look tribe of mentors calm or anywhere
that books are sold at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking annoyance
is a personal question
now it is soon
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by peloton and I'd heard
about peloton over and over again but I
ended up getting a peloton bike in the
whole system after I saw my buddy Kevin
Rose I've known him forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic I asked was a dude you
look great what the hell have you been
up to because he's always doing a weird
diet or another but it only lasts like a
week or two so he always regresses to
the mean after like 75 beers and he said
I've been doing peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes in your schedule or
making it to a studio with some type of
commute etc new classes are added every
day and this includes options led by
elite New York City instructors in your
own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user
interface to keep your attention the
belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in a
living room or in office I actually have
it in a large closet too believe it or
not and it fits with no problem
so peloton is offering all of you guys
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show a
special offer and it is actually special
visit one peloton that's Oh n e PE l OT
o n one peloton calm and enter the code
Tim all caps TI m at checkout to receive
$100 off accessories with your peloton
bike purchase now you might say man
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory category so there's
$100 off is a very legit hundred dollars
off so if you want to get in your
workouts if you want a convenient and
really entertaining way to do
high-intensity interval training or
anything else or you just want to get a
fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one peloton calm and
enter the code to Tim again that's oh
and E PE l OU t om dot-com and enter the
code Tim a check out to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim this episode
is brought to you by convertkit my go-to
email service provider I use them for
everything if you've ever wondered how
professional bloggers podcasters
youtubers and so on can build a platform
they control and get the word out about
their best content email is still the
answer people think it's all social
social social but one algorithm change
and oops bait and switch and I only
reach ten percent of your audience that
is why I've doubled and tripled down on
email after reviewing many different
email service providers I ended up
selecting convertkit for email like 500
Friday which goes out to about a million
people now because convertkit delivers
on what matters most to me at least easy
to use systems split testing and
resending technology both very very
important
high rates of deliverability and great
hands-on customer service so whether you
run a business or simply have say a
serious blog convertkit has integrations
with more than 70 different services
just about anything you might need
including hosting sites like WordPress
e-commerce platforms like Shopify lead
capture technology like bounce exchange
or sumo and many more they also offer a
visual automation builder that makes it
really easy to deliver the right content
to the right people in your audience
just when they want it if you want a
segment in different ways which a lot of
people do convert kit offers plans that
adjust to the size of your business
so it's a good option whether you have a
thousand people or 1 million on your
list and certainly I am planning on
growing and growing and growing and I
don't like switching email service
providers so I thought very carefully
about this before I selected them so
check it out take a look at convertkit
dot-com forward slash Tim that's convert
CEO nver tki t-dot-com forward slash tim
and you can get your first month for
free to kick the tires test it out that
way and give it a shot make sure that it
works for you your business and all of
that goodness if you're like me I hope
you'll find that they get the job done
that's certainly been my experience so
check it out again that's convertkit com
a forward slash Tim for a free month of
email services
why hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
or perhaps you're listening to the brand
new tribe of mentors podcast which is
currently as of this recording number 5
across all of iTunes and Apple podcasts
this is a cross-post episode so it
appears in both places and I'll keep
this intro short this conversation
you're going to hear is with Tim urban
and we'll get into his bio in the actual
conversation it was recorded at Barnes &
Noble in Union Square in New York City
on the launch evening of the tribe of
mentors book you can learn all about
that a tribe of mentors dot-com we had a
blast
the audience was awesome thank you to
everyone who came out and we'll probably
be doing some more live experiments like
this so without further ado please enjoy
my very wide-ranging conversation with
the ever hilarious and fascinating Tim
urban
how's everybody doing my all right this
is exciting thank you all so much for
coming it's real honor and privilege to
have you all here and we're gonna do
something a little bit different tonight
rather than do what is the norm and
perhaps what I've done many times before
which is get up and tell you all about
this book that you already own I thought
we'd do a bonus round with one of the
guests one of the people who was
interviewed for travel Mentors
so I'm going to welcome him to the stage
in just a moment but I'll read the bio
first while I wrestle with the audio and
here we go one of my one of my favorite
people in New York City so I'm excited
and we'll be asking questions I have not
asked him before so this is a rare LIVE
edition of the Tim Ferriss show in some
ways also here we go Tim Urban who is
Tim Urban Twitter Facebook at weight but
why wait but why dot-com
Tim urban is the author of the blog wait
but why and has become one of the
Internet's most popular writers Tim
according to Fast Company has captured a
level of reader engagement that even the
new media giants or that even the new
media giants would be envious of today
wait but why receives more than 1.5
million unique visitors per month among
them Elon Musk and has more than 550,000
email subscribers tim has gained a
number of prominent readers as well like
author Sam Harris and Susan Cain Twitter
co-founder Evan Williams Ted curator
Chris at Ashington that's one of my
buddies hi Chris Anderson and brain
pickings Maria Popova Tim series of
posts after interviewing Elon Musk have
been called by Fox's David Roberts quote
the meatiest most fascinating most
satisfying posts I've read in ages end
quote you can start with the first one
Elon Musk the world's Radice demand
Tim's TED talk inside the mind of a
master procrastinator has received more
than now I checked it yesterday 25
million combined views please welcome to
the stage the incredible
the brilliance and handsome Tim urban
feel like this is like your birthday
party and I'm like stepping in the
middle of Michael sorry on come well you
know I said what other Tim can I bring
into the fall for those people who are
maybe a little older like I am this is
the T to the improved version its
Terminator reference alright so I
figured we'll jump into it what we're
gonna do is we'll have a conversation
which mostly involves me just asking him
questions and then we'll jump into this
fishbowl and answer some of your
questions and then after that we will
have the opportunity we might be here
for a while so I will not be offended if
people are like peace I'm out I don't
want to wait but we will have a chance
to say hello and people who want to have
photographs and so on will be able to do
that okay let's just jump right into it
alright wait but why before we put wine
you and I chatted a little bit about
this I guess feels like a couple of
nights ago but maybe was yesterday I
can't remember it's a big week you
blogged casually for six years or so on
the side can you tell us about that blog
what subjects did you cover what
characterized what you did part-time for
six years it so it was called underneath
the turban so that's a little thing that
I came up with and the turban yes cuz my
name is Tim Urban I uh I was 23 I was in
a second it was not a serious project
and it was very much a side project I it
was actually I think I can credit it
because it credit the fact that it was a
side project for why I was actually able
to kind of be productive because I
didn't have this pressure to do it I was
like you know what's my voice
Who am I is a writer I wasn't a writer I
was just doing something else I was
gonna blog to procrastinate to be doing
which liberated me creatively actually I
was able to kind of you know do my own
thing and you know kind of find my voice
and be you know kind of a little bit you
know courageous at times and I
I think so so for someone like me is
actually like it was like I tricked
myself into actually doing stuff that I
normally probably would have you know
and a little bit more belabor than
trying to get it going bye to javi yeah
what type of subjects was it was it
similar how was it most different and
how was it most similar to wait but what
yeah so it was very much more like a
blog blog you know I'd write about my
day I'd rant about you know going to the
store and then they had McDonald's there
and then they I was like don't get the
six piece nugget you know get the four
and then I ordered the ten and then they
actually had the end of the night so
they give me 18 and then I eat all 18
and that it was like that kind of like
story about my day very much like just
the top of my head just typing
publishing you know and it never it was
it was a small little passionate
following of like 700 people like six
comments on a thing and that was that
and it was um it was this side project
but it was a way for me to actually
write like 300 blog posts over a
six-year span what we're this were there
any seeds from that experience that then
informed wait but why and why did you
create wait but why yeah and where's the
name come from yeah so so I I was able
to kind of hone my voice through writing
300 blog post I went back at the early
ones I I winced it like the tones I was
using so it was you know I 300 blog post
will teach you what you liked you know
the voice you like to write in um and so
that's one thing and then I also like
towards the end Isis decided one night
to try to draw something and I kind of
said let me you know I was gonna try to
depict this concept that that was funny
when someone you know was like
doppelganger or day on Facebook and
someone posts a doppelganger that's way
better looking than they are I always
think that's kind of hilarious and I was
like I'm gonna draw this I figured
there's a messy looking and then like a
handsome stick figure with like so wave
of hair and I so I did that and it hit
me that I like I I was like that would
be better and drawing and I realized I
like that and so I discovered that there
too so when I started wait but why did
that other people also respond
positively to that or did he better yes
they did yeah you've got great feedback
and then I started just every post on
life is a glass seven posts on the blog
all had drawings it's like I discovered
that at the very end
so then it was time to start a new
project why was it time to start a new
project why not continue writing about
the chicken mcnuggets good it's not I'm
not trying to be a dick no no it's fair
and I had I also write about chicken
nuggets I'm sorry
this family programming not sure sorry
no I am I it was uh it was time in my
life in general to like turn all my
attention not a third of my attention to
one creative project it was always I'm
doing something with my full time and
that I'm doing these like two creative
projects on the side I'm gonna be a pain
in the ass I apologize but that's my
nature why was it time like what
realization or conversation or getting
fired or whatever catalyzed the decision
you know what it's it's time for me to
put all my eggs in one basket creatively
it's this thing you do that makes me
love your podcast it's stressful being
the person but you know so for me it was
actually I spent years from ages 22 to
31 like hating myself a little bit
because I was burning to do something
creative whether it was writing or music
or something and and I always was doing
them on the side you know I it was like
that that kind of that kind of just leap
of faith in my own kind of ability to do
something creative full-time took me
nine years nine years that uh
that I wasn't very happy and so I
finally said you know I died this is I
have to do something full-time because I
always thought if I could just do
something full-time and all the energy
from all of these things into one thing
it would go it would go well so I
decided you know I actually owned a
business with my friend Andrew Finn and
it was the fact that the business got
into a decent enough spot that you know
we were able to start something new and
kind of that's when I jumped on what was
the business it's a test prep company
you know this is a great business so
mention on a is a very successful
novelist also got his beginnings it's a
good starter a good like starter
business Asylum Robinson as well so
three people in this book that's crazy
getting together now who knew who knew I
was on to like the starter business I
it's just procrastinating from my music
career is actually all I was doing when
I started I was tutoring on the side and
then of course you know the other side
things ended up taking all my time which
is what a classic procrastinator would
dip but yeah just simple kind of you
know you each session pays for itself
you don't need overhead you know you do
the beginning you don't need any
full-time employees and so we but we
built it up to the point where he had
good full time employees good enough to
run run it kind of without both of us
there and so it was time to start
something and we've done this a couple
years ago we started a podcast at back
in 2011 with the theory that podcasts
were just gonna get bigger and they did
unfortunately we didn't know how to
build a good app we built a bad average
didn't build a bad app but we but now it
was a couple years later it was time for
something new and I said I'm gonna jump
on this and say I need to do something
creative let me see if I can do it as
also a business that like we can kind of
own together you can run our tutoring
company I'm gonna go and start something
and you know I was between kind of like
writing a musical which is a terrible
business I wouldn't want to drag him
into that or writing maybe a Content
website that's that can you know a
platform media platform that can that
can be a business so that's why that's
where we settle on that I knew those
were things I could do creatively well
and so we settled on this and the I'd
that premise was like what if I took
instead of five hours a week to write a
blog 60 hours a week to write a blog
what will happen
I took the things I knew that I had
gotten good at on the other blog which
was just kind of writing colloquially
and and drawing stick figures and
started it from there what is the origin
of the name 16 hours on GoDaddy
searching for coms and man there's not
much there is not much but I didn't I
wanted it to be something it wouldn't
pigeonhole it into you know all right so
I mean were you just typing in random
combinations of words or is there some
itch that you had related to the
expression I mean you do have a habit I
was imagining oh it's because people
would say something to you and you want
to test the assumptions or you wouldn't
accept it at face value sig oh wait but
why you know that was in my head how I
explained it
I wish it was that situation I checked
two thousand things and go dad 150 came
out my girlfriend knocked out 140
immediately was like absolutely not that
leaves me with ten where I was kind of
like okay these are all bad which is the
least bad which if the sites good it can
seem kind of cool suddenly maybe but it
starts off bad but then it's not that
and there's some of the other ones were
just extremely embarrassing so I'm just
gonna dangle that hook in front of me
were there any that I can give some
examples to if it makes you feel any
better if bully titles that are horrible
but were there any that you really liked
that your girlfriend shot down you were
like we can both do this embarrassing
actually just you house okay I'll kick
it off so there was for what ended up
being the 4-hour workweek
there was lifestyle hustling glad I
didn't use that there was drug dealing
for fun and profit which was promptly
vetoed by every retailer thank God there
was a broadband and whites and I mean it
goes on it goes on so sometimes you need
life to save you from yourself
those are kind of good those are these
are in sensical like they have some kind
of I understand two of those three all
right I'll take two out of three that's
partially cuz I'm giving you like the
better of the worst yeah but new your
turn
miniature King calm I was in a deep
GoDaddy spiral you know you have ever
been on one of these it gets weird it
gets really weird so I'm there and I'm
like I'm like into this idea of a king
cuz I pictured the playing card King and
I'm like so a miniature King and I
suddenly got obsessed with it I was like
he has little eggs and he's very angry
he's very like cranky and it is like big
adult people walking by him he's on the
ground he's like two feet tall and my
girlfriend was like Jesus not
but I got so addicted to the King
concept that when I started wait for why
I meet the logo playing oh you know he's
just thinking and pissed off that's
amazing you're like okay I like it but
since then I thought you know what you
can do this happens all do you still am
in your kingdom I own miniature King
calm and about like 15 others yeah yeah
there's a lot Jesus half bro is gonna do
am a sight we're just I'm Jesus's
half-brother and how he's like but he's
not like the divine one he's just like
born from like Jesus his mom with like
some guy and he's he's a look at what
could go wrong with that
yeah he's got all kinds of all kinds of
psychological issues going on you know
it's just as his life trying to figure
out his career what what were if you
look back cuz I look back and I remember
the first my first attempts at blogging
and like the first 12 posts and I mean
they're they've thankfully mostly been
forgotten over time but what were your
first you had you had more practice NIDA
you'd already put in three hundred reps
what were the first poses like do
remember any of the topics yeah well so
well my early blog I mean the topics
were they was like they start with like
three sentence things like one of them
that I feel like the first three was you
know the title is frankly and then it
said like if peeing in the shower is
wrong I don't want to be right that was
a blog post back in the day a
flash-forward six years now wait but why
I knew more and I think I I knew right
away it was gonna be like long and
thorough cuz that site just you know it
was in my own site and I you know I know
I could get into depth if I if I you
know could just you know go longer and
so firsts with the beginning I was
anonymous and I'm sure you dealt with
this too at some point you know you have
to it's the get attention phase so I
anonymous the only platform marketing
platform I have is my personal Facebook
page
and I started with seven ways to be
insufferable on Facebook which sounds
like a BuzzFeed headline but it was like
much more in-depth
I'd like gotten to the deep dark
psychology of why like you know like why
it's the Wild West of social etiquette
and why we're all like our very
embarrassing version of ourselves on it
and what the different like qualities of
negative human qualities that come
through on it so that was the very first
one I actually went to Easter Island for
a month before I started wait but why
did just alone in the middle of nowhere
write blog posts and pink like my
favorite one to put on first to just
kind of like figure out what and that
was the winner why do you pick Easter
hunt I like the fact that you could take
like a 2,000 mile a yard stick and swing
it around the island and not hit any
people like that was cool to me I was
just so isolated Plus like the statues
and the whole thing
and I was kind of like I've always
wanted to go I was either there or was
gonna go to lift-away Nia in the winter
and just creep out some small village
yeah well well you could tell me a small
village to creep out sometime and they
were just gonna and I just talked to
someone in the really you may actually
like a right aroused suspicion if you're
like this like foreign are like working
every day I'm just writing vlog in
isolation you know small Lithuanian
village yeah sounds like a George
Clooney spy movie yeah but I do when I
do want to do that in the mid dead of
winter go to like a small like cold
village somewhere anyway so how did the
blog post do that one it did well the
very first one and like I chose well it
how didn't you choose it relative to the
other ideas that you had trying to do
some combo of like something that I
thought was like true enough to me that
represented like the kind of quality I
wanted to do it all so that we could go
viral just beginning how can I go viral
because that's the one year is 2013
summer of 2013 all right yeah so that
post did really well it got 500,000
uniques a month that's it yeah my whole
blog got 250,000 uniques in six years so
this was like okay longer like getting
into more serious topics and insulting
people like you know it's it's it's on
to something plus you know I would I
didn't know at the time
was that 2013 was a pretty magical year
to be promoting content on Facebook this
was that Facebook was decided let's show
everyone just how powerful we are
and they started made this is why
BuzzFeed exploded then upworthy you
first heard of it in 2013 why we all
know about these sites exploded because
Facebook's algorithm basically said
anyone posting content were going to
show it to half a million people I was
in the right place at the right time and
so that was very helpful as well yeah
yeah I just - maybe underscore one thing
because for instance I've started my
first business it was the Golden Age of
Google AdWords I mean it was shooting
fish in a barrel so inexpensive and then
the 4-hour workweek launched it was at
the same time at South by Southwest when
Twitter was effectively publicly debuted
I mean there were big screens displaying
all of the tweets in the world going on
which happened to be concentrated right
nos in Texas because it was so small and
I would say that any time is the right
time in some way right so these
opportunities were talking about there
are these opportunities right now you
just have to try to snip them out or
deshee in the dark and hope that you'll
catch some tailwind but everybody has it
seems with these stories some element of
luck involved but you can't improve the
odds that's just well right there's like
10 waves you know throughout your time
one of the waves is cresting when you're
starting you don't know which one but
something is cresting at the time it's
the perfect time to start something for
some reason always right and in every
story where you find a component of good
timing there's usually a quite a bad
time greatly podcast app like you were
paddling for the right way you're just
doing it years too early yeah all right
so I want to bring another figure
another character into this picture
who's Winston can you tell us about
Winston please Winston's a close friend
of mine I met him in 2005 when he was
three months old I purchased him and
we've lived happily together ever since
he was the size of a golf ball at the
time now he's the size of a football
which is a huge upgrade for him he's a
tortoise but he's um he's very lovable
he's uh he's kind of my apartment
screensaver like I'm just sitting there
honest but would be at just an empty
still scene and there's this like
moseying things little moseying dinosaur
that moseys buy and who doesn't want
that you should all own a tortoise it's
weird that most of you don't own her
tortoise why didn't you name him Winston
because I thought he had a Churchill
look damn or it's more that Churchill
has a tortoise lady to him I'm sort of
imagining the I know they're not the
same but like the sea turtles and
Finding Nemo it's like yeah I can see
that
maybe yeah we'd spend less charisma but
otherwise yeah when I look at some of
your posts and I've had my my life very
directly and profoundly impacted by by
some of your writing particularly about
time remaining with the same parents or
family but when I look at some of your
very research heavy posts and it feels
funny did call them posts whether it's
on AI or other topics that confuse a lot
of people I mean we're talking about for
those of you who don't have any
familiarity in some cases 50,000 words
70,000 words
that's a book everybody how long is the
4-hour workweek 4-hour workweek that's a
solid now it's deceptive to use page
count but that's how I think it's about
I want to say what 420 pages for 430
pages and it's not gigantic dr. Seuss
print so it's probably closer if I'm
guessing taking a stab to the hundred
thousand hundred twenty thousand word
mark I seem to have sort of word
inflation with the books okay great
they're getting bigger but when you when
you're tackling one of these posts what
are some of the approaches
questions you ask that allow you to
write something better and different
because presumably many people are out
there trying to learn about these
various topics and yet you put out these
posts that are the size of books that
end up going viral and you make
complicated seemingly complicated topics
very digestible so what is your approach
to tackling a topic like AI yeah um so
it's it's pretty simple for me first of
all like I just just I'd do this kind of
weird thing where I assume that my
audience is a picture like a stadium
full of meat so it's a narcissistic
fantasy you know but it's like you know
it's just I'm just writing for two I'm
writing the exact post that I would be
thrilled to get right so I'm just trying
out my focus group right there right in
my head and it's easy because like you
know we're all kind of like special
unique people except not really there's
like a hundred thousand copies of each
of you out there somewhere and the truth
is like you know if I just write for me
there's a lot of people that have my
exactly your taste I just know that so I
start there it's kind of like Who am I
writing for that that makes it easy and
so we're something like AI if there's a
one through ten scale of how much you
know about something ten is world
leading expert you know you no one has
absolutely never heard of the term you
know I started that two or three on most
stuff like most laymen I'm a layman
right up at everything and so then I
spend it just added my curiosity is the
driver I pick topics I'm excited to dig
into and I'll spend however long it
takes sometimes it's one day sometimes
it's three weeks sometimes it's three
months but I'll take as long as I need
to to learn enough to get me to maybe
like a five or a six out of ten you know
I'm not gonna get a PhD I'm not gonna
spend five years getting myself to an
eight or a nine but I'm gonna get myself
to a six where I'm like I can answer
basically any question a layman asks me
I can do a Q&A with an audience on this
topic for ten hours and I'll have a
pretty good solid answer to everything
not that I know necessarily that
everything but I know when the experts
don't know the truth and they're arguing
I know what the experts say about
basically everything so I get myself to
that level and then I think about okay
so experts have sometimes a hard time
explaining cuz they haven't been antutu
in decades sometimes and they have this
jargon and they don't remember what it's
like to be a 2 out of 10 I was there
three weeks ago I know exactly what my
readers know about this and I know
exactly what so I just look at the road
I went down to get myself to a six and I
think about you know what how can I do
that roadway more efficiently if I could
go do it again now how could I do it in
a much more fun way you know and what's
what's this fun story I can tell to
bring readers from the two-door six and
so that's my challenge then is to
basically package the road I just went
down for three weeks and make it an
hour-and-a-half package instead okay not
surprisingly I have some follow-up
questions let's pick a subject have you
written about cryptocurrency or
blockchain not yet
Oh perfect so highly requested time
right I'm sure it is now the reason I
ask is that much like a I I have seen
dozens of people attempt to explain
without misrepresenting cryptocurrency
and blockchain 101 for the masses and it
seems like almost every single attempt
has failed if you were to take that
assignment on where would you start so I
would
III don't always start I feel like I'm
lying folded in a room I'm just trying
to figure out we're even the wall zebra
you know where is the furniture I just
want to start and understand what I even
need to learn so I'm gonna get a picture
of the topic and then I can start diving
in going on various rabbit holes and and
usually going outside the topic go a
rabbit hole outside the topic is
procrastination but it also often you
know it gives you even more context
you'll find some metaphor out there that
you end up bringing back so I'll just
read and
and watch youtube videos all on the
internet how do you search so reading
are we talking you start at Wikipedia is
that Ground Zero yeah start at Wikipedia
all right for just a basic foundation
Wikipedia is good at telling you where
the walls are just let me even
understand the topic in general and
Wikipedia is a lot of good good
knowledge on it so I'll go there and
then I'll go to the bottom Wikipedia and
start clicking on all the reference
links and I'll you know usually Google
like you know block chain PDF and you
end up finding all these superbly boring
you know journal articles and then I'll
go on YouTube it's a lot of good people
smart teacher and explaining stuff on
YouTube they're not gonna explain the
whole thing usually they're gonna
explain one part maybe I realized that
to understand blockchain you need to
first go down three layers you need to
build a foundation that begins with
understanding what encryption is you to
understand how encryption works in
public keys and private keys that's when
you can start to on top of that build an
understanding of what a ledger is that
would be on these different computers
and how it could possibly be secure and
by the time you get to blockchain you're
like eight layers up but so I'll go find
a YouTube video not on blockchain but on
encryption and then I'll find a youtube
video explaining what Ledger's are in
general I wasn't reading about the
history of Ledger's where they're used
in the world and you know encryption and
where it was in you know how it was
invented how its evolved and you just
keep doing this and then the reason I
it's easy for me this part is because
I'm super curious so the more and the
more I learn the less a key the topic
gets when the topic gets uh Nicky it
gets should start to be super delicious
the opposite and then and then I can't
be nothing I start to it's so fun
suddenly I can get it and then I just
want to like fill in the knowledge and I
wanna watch YouTube video already know
the answer to just feel good about oh
man I already knew everything you say
this is great but it's a little fuzzy
you hear seven different people
articulate it in seven ways and you just
rounds out your understanding and by the
end they start to be like I totally get
this finding I find a video on YouTube
so last I checked which is not recently
I YouTube was the second largest search
engine in the
it's a lot of great stuff there's also a
lot of nonsense how do you search so
what are the terms how do you sort them
how do you go about picking properly
well so Google it's I just I will Google
like blockchain leave that in a you know
window open a new window and on Google
Bitcoin new window a theory of new
window cryptocurrency new window like
decentralized systems crypto new window
like quick cryptocurrency is [ __ ]
new window like you know whatever and
I'll just keep going and I'll just think
of anything and then each one of those
windows I go back to and I just hold
down command and I just click click
click click click click now 10 tabs 10
tabs 10 tabs I just go and read
everything so that's you Google you know
again Dianna I don't have to discern I
don't care if this gizmo to article is
gonna be you know really useful or you
know whether it's gonna be accurate
because it's the beginning process is
just if you read 70 articles that may or
may not have validity to them
the total some of them actually you
start to understand what what do we know
as a species where are we all agreeing
and then we're clearly a lot of people
don't know what they're talking about or
there's this broad you know business
it's kind of dichotomy of a view in this
one area these people and the disease
people YouTube it's kind of the same
thing I'll just start watching without
discerning again if you're a
procrastinator it's fantastic because
you don't feel bad about just watching
endlessly when you're taking all of your
time and it's not where you're supposed
you're doing it feels great so I'll just
I'll just watch and then of course the
sidebar starts to figure out you YouTube
very quickly and Google will there
figure out what you're doing and then
YouTube will start to put all the things
on the side for me plus you start to see
name she trusts make money and cryptic
earnest yeah well even just it's funny
I'm just running a post now on like to
this political stuff and you know
normally my sidebar is like look how
much of an idiot Trump is and his voters
and then I go to the I'm now trying tell
you know I was googling all these
conservative things and except writing
about both sides of stuff and suddenly
you the internet starts to indoctrinate
me the other way and they're like look
at this like wise Trump voter like
embarrass this like you know and I look
over and kind of like an offense like
and a couple hours later I'm like
Trump's the best like so like YouTube
figures out your angle and it will start
to kind of like feed you stuff and then
there's certainly if you Trump steel
Hank and John Green like I trust them
you know Kirk Kirk Assad I trust them
CGP Grey has to trust him so certain you
know you'll see certain names you trust
minutephysics great so there's also that
and it's same with the same with them
you know Google of course like I'll
trust certain sources more than others
and once you've ingested massive amounts
of information and you've established a
basic map for the territory what do you
think are the tools or approaches
anything at all that I'll that help you
to be so good at teaching these subjects
in the way that you present it or
structure your pieces yeah well so again
the starting point is I'm like I just
went through this and I have to teach
myself and I was bad at teaching myself
I don't know what I was doing so now if
I could I the experience of a learner is
fresh in my head so that's the first
thing that's helpful but then I just I
always basically with almost any explain
or post like that I just zoom out
helicopter up like you know if you're if
you're looking at the land and you see
kind of like a beach a little beach and
then there's is a curve around I don't
know that's how I feel like a lot of the
articles on AI or cryptocurrency are
they show you a piece of Beach and they
and then the other might have a full
understanding but you just look they're
just they're just describing the beach
so you take a helicopter up and you're
like oh okay wait a second this is a big
river and there's a there and you go
take them further and you're like oh no
this is a this is kind of a tributary
that goes into the ocean and and now
you're kind of up where airplanes go and
maybe even the International Space
Station goes and you're like okay this
is actually what's going on so I start
there myself as a thinker and then when
I'm trying to explain I'm just gonna
start there which is why you know people
make fun of me he's like I'll write
about three different things and they
all start at the big bang I have to
basically go back to the now but like
sometimes like it's helpful to you just
like you just um by the time you get
from the Big Bang to now suddenly it's
like we're all like we can
see the whole coastline and now that
Beach suddenly make sense and then I try
to make it fun also because who wants to
like it so many you know like the
journal articles for example the experts
like they're often just they don't cuz
they're not ready to entertain you know
and they're just and it's just bad it's
like textbooks and school works so bad
they were so boring part of the reason I
like YouTube is because the people who
end up with a lot of views on YouTube
that are gonna end up you know on my
recommend recommended thing they're they
have an eye for entertainment so I try
to do the same thing as well and if you
were to ask say friends of yours who are
fans of your writing what your
ingredients for entertaining are what
might they say or just to ask you I'm
just not sure I don't yeah I don't want
you to be overly self-deprecating I was
trying to figure out what makes
entertaining because it is clearly
entertaining well again entertaining
means ten different things of ten
different people I get you know every
different uses I get nine emails from
like you know mothers and Kansas angry
at me for swearing but like you know it
depends on you know it's you know it's
um I think trying to add sense of humor
into basically everything treating it
light good metaphors you know an act for
me lots of visuals I'm a visual learner
if I see a block of text and I'm just
scrolling down I'm kind of upset it's
like feels like homework but if I scroll
down and every few paragraphs there's a
chart there's a comic I'm suddenly like
okay this is fun I'm kind of excited
like and so that's how I think so I try
to do that that's what I would want so I
like I like you know like there's so
many things where you can just do a
funny stick drawing or a really good
diagram and just it's just way clearer
and sticks in your head more you know if
I'm gonna talk about procrastination I
can talk about like the the limbic
system and you know talk about you know
how it works and it's our fight or
flight zone or I can make an instant
gratification monkey and like because
that is essentially what it is and
that's more memorable and I think more
fun to read at the time so you've really
in my opinion exhibited a mastery for
taking what many people would consider
extremely intimidating subjects
many of them involved in forging what
we're going to experience as a species
as the future so I'd like to talk about
the future for a second and I want to
read a quote here all right believe that
you wrote or said this so incredi is
wrong I always thought the future would
be intense but now I think the future is
going fully [ __ ] crazy okay so what
are a few things that you're excited
about or see coming down the pike
in the future doesn't have to be one or
two babysit could be many it is gonna be
crazy and here's why so the first
thought a lot of people have is that
it's naive to think that the future is
goodness all weird the end of times
everyone thinks that you know you know
you're just another naive person that
thinks they live in a special time
because and the reason we all have that
instinct is because we're biology moves
very slowly it devolves very very slowly
so 50,000 years is nothing in biology
and evolution so we barely changed
meaning we are still a baby born today
is a baby that is perfectly optimized to
live in a tribe in Ethiopia and 50,000
BC and it is everything about it is
ready for survival in that world but
what we've done is taken that baby away
from its home planet and brought it to
another planet which is the earth in
2017 and that baby isn't made very well
for this world none of us are okay so so
the first thing to think about is just
that a lot of our instincts and a lot of
our you know intuitions are actually
gonna be inherently wrong we're gonna be
living in a delusion that was helpful
back then today justice is not great so
the reason the way you can cut through
this and actually see reality when
you're the bait that baby is not it's
not seeing reality isn't helpful to that
baby fitting in with the tribe is and
believing what the tribe believes is so
today we want to see reality and so you
can do things like you can just look at
the facts sometimes so imagine the the
it's gonna be a long answer
I'm imagine that I have a lot to say
about this imagine that this is what I'm
saying the zoom out
it's a think answer server can't be
short in my head so imagine the human
history is about a thousand cent you get
comfortable folks yeah settle in a
thousand centuries of human history a
hundred thousand years ok so each two
centuries is a page in a book ok how
many pages of this 500 pages actually
you know whatever anyone maybe the
mapping is no no they're finding older
human remains so fine so one hundred and
forty thousand years every page in this
book that you're holding is 200 years in
human history ok so page 1 through 650
of that book hunter-gatherers if you're
an alien reading this book to understand
what happened on this planet you are
bored I mean is this really boring page
650 10,000 years ago you have the
Agricultural Revolution okay wait so
suddenly people are coming together
forming cities okay they're starting to
actually form larger civilization they
have a collective intelligence that's
starting to form it can should compare
notes they can kind of create a
knowledge tower that like is bigger than
any one of them it's very interesting
stuff so that's 50 pages ago then it
gets boring again for a while okay page
690 out of 700 right a little tiny end
of the book here you have Jesus you have
you know 693 you have the advent of
Islam the Roman Empire happens two pages
ago it's already done
697 you have imperialism for the first
time you have countries this is one
thing that happened in the last three
pages page 698 you have the
Enlightenment you have the Renaissance
you're things like this it discovered
that there's galaxies telescope page 699
you have you finally get to the
beginning of the US and the beginning of
kind of constitutional democracies right
now page 700 happens which is from about
200 years ago to today okay so the
beginning of page 700 the alien turns
the page Industrial Revolution happens
okay big deal big change okay and has
reach down the page things start to go
crazy you start to have you have a 699
pages this alien is read this boring-ass
species has composed
communicated through letters and talking
you know he was excited about language
500 pages ago now he's bored smoke
signals firing a cannonball in the air
stuff like that okay
suddenly on page 700 we go to the space
station and we made the space station we
have the moon we have airplanes gift
cards just on page seven hundred six
hundred ninety nine pages okay we have a
beat we only communicate through well we
have these kind of you know simple
transportation communication now we have
we have FaceTime okay we have you know
we have we have we have telephone we
have the Internet I mean crazy right
less than a billion people for the first
six hundred ninety nine pages on page
seven hundred alone we crossed the one
two three four five six and seven
billion person marks so the aliens
reading and like his his wife comes in
is like hey we're gonna have
intersection option
so the most intrepid II think something
what is about to happen to this species
this is go this is crazy
what just happened on this page this is
when we're born we're born at the end of
page 700 okay so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why what do you think the future is
gonna be like I'm like oh page 701 and
they're like no one is there's no way is
that [ __ ] just goes bonkers
yeah the first three sentences a page
701 will take us to 2025 when they
predict that like you know AI is gonna
basically infiltrate every single
industry and part of our lives the way
electricity did in like a 10 year span
them in 1880's I mean that's the first
three sentences so to me I see
revolution see onset the pages the first
half of page 701 the first quarter a
page 701 I see revolutions and you know
VRA are I see revolutions and AI and see
revolutions and brain machine interfaces
we're gonna be able to think thoughts to
each other it's way cooler than language
for the first time we're I see
revolutions and genetic stuff your
grandkids are gonna be like you just had
a baby and hoped it was a good baby it's
gonna seem crazy this is so primitive
and you can just go on and on and on
with things that you look how about this
one okay what are the major leagues for
life like that you can count on one hand
for all of life simple cell to complex
cell
big one complex l2 multi cell big one we
have animals now ocean to land big one I
would say the fourth that fits on this
same list is going from one planet to
multi planets as a civilization that's
happening in the next decade with SpaceX
no one's talking about it yet but they
will be I mean just the fact that like
we're gonna witness in our lifetimes one
of the great leaps for all of life like
this isn't normal
okay so I want to talk about extra
planetary just a couple of curious
notions that have been bouncing around
my own head if you had to bet on more
humans inhabiting say Mars or inhabiting
space stations that don't have to
conquer a separate gravity where would
you bet there are competing camps or at
least
technologists who are looking at saying
happening other planets or saying no
that makes no sense because now you're
dealing with a separate environment
gravitational field etc we're gonna just
build space stations yeah it's a Mars
for a while
Mars is probably gonna have a million
people you know the next five or six
decades and then middle eventually
probably end up at a billion people but
I think Space Station's in the long run
way better I mean it's gonna seem really
crappy to be on a planet it's gonna be
you know being on a planets gonna seem
very old-school and very kind of rough
compared to the Space Station's we can
imagine dealing with weather it's gonna
seem crazy that you'd have to deal with
weather that you had to deal with things
like climate change is just not not our
problem if to deal with bugs
it's my I be so happy there's no bugs on
the space station so so I think in the
long run that but I have a more
important question because are you gonna
go to Mars no no well not in the near
term I don't be the first monkey shot at
the first Lars I'll lend quite a few
people work out the kinks on that one I
mean we can't even figure out how to
upgrade iOS without replacing I with
[ __ ] images like I'm gonna let
someone shoot me to Mars
no no not early no again a picture is 20
years from now and the last you know
every 26 months you know earth lapse
Mars okay and they end up next to each
other that's when you have this window
to go so every 26 months there's gonna
be a fleet colonial fleet heading there
and another fleet coming back bringing
people back round-trip tickets how about
all the different people on the legs
right yeah no no exactly like
first-class things will be like fancy
people but everyone jumping around
bouncing around with the gravity it
sounds great that zero-gravity cruise
ship so question is for you
it's 2038 okay it's already 2045 and
it's it's been proven for the last like
20 trips back where no one's gotten hurt
it's totally safe would I visit yeah
yeah what's the total time invested at
this going in the Train let station
first the shortest round-trip you can do
is a 52 month
I would I would strongly consider it
okay I heard I heard Jeff Bezos say
recently on stage you know before you
think about going to Mars spend a month
in Antarctica that's a cakewalk
Oh Antarctic is way better than Mars
yeah Antarctica but 15 or 20 degrees
colder you can't breathe the air you
can't be outside in the Sun without a
radiation suit so I think it depends a
lot on the brochure of Mars Club Med
that I receive yes okay all right
shifting gears a little bit ai do you
think it is an existential threat or not
and if so what is the time horizon for
becoming a a imminent existential threat
so this is the one of the great
questions
you know I a I is probably the subject
I've talked to most experts on so I'm
not an expert but I really know what the
experts think and I try to keep up to
date they change their minds a lot uh so
what will be fine nowhere else they'll
be fine the world ends what I find is
very few people who don't think this is
gonna basically take over everything the
question is when and I was surprised
that even the people that are
pessimistic they kind of think oh it
might be a hundred years from now on
most people think 50 thirty and people
at deep mind these days at Google which
is like the leading AI company now
they're saying things like 10 and this
is when I say 10 10 till what I'm
talking about
you know before any of this moment
happens it's a good there's to
understand AI you have to think about
two things there's narrow intelligence
and there's a general intelligence so
humans have general intelligence we are
smart across the board okay we have we
have social skills we have creativity we
can understand math we can read we can
be creative we can learn from experience
you just name it name anything here this
can kind of learn how to be smart there
okay but when you think about ai ai is
way better than any human at the things
that's good at like chess the world
chess master right of course and it's
the it's the world master and everything
that it does well but it's only good at
that one thing for this ai your phone
does a yeah your car there's AI running
most stuff at this point but it's
good at one thing so the question is
when will a I become gain that same
breath that we have when will it become
broadly smart and until then it's still
gonna change the world it's still gonna
take a huge amount of jobs and create a
whole you know a whole bunch more so
it's gonna be a massive group of changes
that happen even before we get general
intelligence but the question that I was
referring to before is when do we get to
this level where AI is now smart like we
are way way smarter what Nick Bostrom
calls super intelligence where it's it's
as smarter than us as we are than
monkeys yeah so basically if you picture
like not only can a monkey not like
build this room or not only can you know
you look out in this night sky you see
little lights moving around you know you
would you're so smart we put those there
we put airplanes and satellites in the
night sky right so not only can a monkey
not do that um you can show the monkey
the light so just building you can't you
can't even understand that you did it it
just will think that it's just there
that's just us moving the star right so
we're talking about something that not
only can we not do what this thing can
do we can't even understand that it did
it even if it tried to explain it that's
how smart this thing is it's a really
crazy concept so things that we think
are hard like curing disease poverty you
know climate change name it you know
anything that we consider a challenge
easy piece of cake for the AI so that's
the really exciting side and then
there's that what if we're not in
control of it the way we want to be not
that it's gonna be evil that's this
anthropomorphize a ssin that people do
and they try to apply human stuff to
this thing that's not human but when you
build a house and there's an anthill
there you're not like haha death to the
ends you just built a house and they're
in the way so you killed them big deal
right the fear is that the ant doing its
thing and then it just we're kind of in
the way and we programmed it in a way
that we didn't think of this thing but
now it's too powerful we can't change it
and and we're toast or it gets it gets
annoyed that we're doing something to it
but it doesn't want and we're toast
so you have some high stakes here and
which is why Hey basically we're gonna
have God on earth because we can play
God to every other animal right
even a chick chicks are really smart
until we put him in the cage now what
are you gonna do we haven't gotten we
have a Taser even poison its food chimps
are nothing compared to our godlike
ability because we have a little
intelligence gap over them little in the
scheme of things when this thing has a
big intelligence gap over us it truly
can play God to us what the question is
is it good god they could solve all of
our problems or is it like one of those
gods in the Old Testament like that guy
so this is what this is what they're
talking about this is why a I safety is
so important but most of the money in
time is going into AI development right
now it's a lot last question and we'll
go to go to audience questions how do
you view happiness just to bring it back
to things that we may be able to
influence it at least speaking for
myself and a lot of people in this room
how do you view or define happiness for
yourself if you do it all yeah well I
kind of think of um there's two kinds of
happiness that you have to kind of deal
with both one is like micro happiness
like are your Tuesday's good are you
generally having a good Tuesday and then
there's like macro happiness like are
you present are you like yeah I'll dig
into this current life for twenty years
I love it or are you like I was for nine
years after college which is like well
I'm doing this now but I really want to
like I should be doing you know and
that's macro happiness so I think you
have to worry about both I think that
the most important one to get right at
the beginning at least is macro I think
if your macro happiness isn't there you
know you're gonna you're gonna have
you're gonna you're gonna feel
frustrated kind of you're have a cloud
over you and then I think you can work
on micro happiness which is about
lifestyle this is what you're so good at
and I think a lot of people here you
know really both for both kind of
happiness as they look to you because
you have a lot of good advice but I
think the micro you really have you
focus so hard on like just really
crushing like a Tuesday and and I think
like but but all life is is literally a
Tuesday again and again and then you die
so I like crushing the Tuesday's good
title of my next book let's get good at
right whites and and Tuesdays
but so yeah and the hard thing that's
hard is a lot of times we assume that
it's the external world we have to
succeed we have to you know get this
relationship and then we'll be and you
know this is kind of cliche but we know
that it's it's messing with your
internal expectations it's getting your
mind in the right place and and and kind
of seeing reality and get see what what
is your ego and what is your fear and
what is kind of you know worrying about
judgment and what is actually real that
matters to you it and realizing that a
lot of the perceived risk isn't really
dangerous and a lot of the perceived
reward isn't really gratifying and it's
all there in front of you you can just
look past your primates itself with your
very rational you know intelligent self
and just see it and then learn to
internalize it often suddenly the
happiness is there you know become very
clear how to work themselves out and
it's up and often we haven't spending
all our time trying to you know get to
those happinesses with the primate kind
of self in charge and that usually
doesn't get us there so to add to that
reality - expectations is that a useful
framework for defining happiness do you
think yeah I mean if so you just say you
know your happiness is like an equation
reality - expectations is your happiness
and and so you can work on two things
you can work on improving your reality
or you can work on not lowering but kind
of like refining your expectations to
reflect what actually matters cube which
will almost always end up with them
lowering in a certain sense and maybe
maybe going up in another sense but you
know the classic trap of course is like
you know you're in a better place than
you were 10 years ago but you're just as
unhappy because you're the hedonic
treadmill concept is this term that
psychologists use that you know you just
your happiness goes up something really
good happens even like you know the
little example is you get a new you buy
something new and you're wake up in the
morning like dude my iPhone x10 and
you're like all happy and then like you
know every day that that goes down in
six days later it's just your stupid
iPhone again but we use this in a macro
sense you get the new job you finally
get into a really good relationship you
work it out or you know you have a sick
friend or a parent and then they they
get healthy and Wow and then
just you know so they obviously way to
to get off the treadmill is it's obvious
just SAS up or grab it
gratitude there's like what I have what
I want and like looking up we're gonna
be really unhappy and if you can you
know even Mountain tea was growing
underneath you but you're not even
looking at it you're just looking up all
the time it's gonna seem like everything
sucks if you're looking down you look at
this mountain it's amazing look at all
the things that I have like you're gonna
be really happy so like that the
gratitude things are really all the you
know the things just to write the three
good things that happened that day every
night before you go to bed right three
good things that happened and why they
happen the reason that people want you
that psychologists say this is good it
because it trains your brain to all day
be thinking wait what's good I need to
do this thing tonight like it's just
what's good what's good you're suddenly
you're looking down and all these things
that are good in your life as opposed to
kind of looking up at what sucks what
sucks about the situation how is the
world wronging me which is a pure recipe
for unhappiness
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna try to put a
little icing on top just just to add to
that which is reading recently about
some of the supposedly objectively
assess happiest places on earth and if
you look at them three of them are Costa
Rica Depot think Oh Buddha you gonna put
all my school you know but long okay
screwed up my gender already bad to do
in these days huh alright at least I did
in Spanish uh so moving on who you I'm
gonna move move on quickly Costa Rica
Singapore they sing porn is you're gonna
shout okay I'm all for it
you don't see it as much in Singapore
and then Denmark alright soon
all right well you can you can write a
letter
I love Norway but I will I will I will
rely on National Geographic you can
write them an angry letter they are very
communicative that's fine
so Norway awesome but I can only speak I
can only speak to the dance but I would
give you the official gold medal but the
silver medal for the dance and I want to
point out a couple of things knowing
people in all three places that in
Singapore
there's very much an optimization for
improving your reality it's very sort of
achievement focused and there's a large
economic component nonetheless the
various combination of factors lead them
to be in the great top on the perhaps
opposite side of that equation are at
least in the alternate side you have the
Danes and I know a lot of Danes
and I remember one point without even
bringing up any of this I said you guys
are apparently really happy why do you
think that is as a group they said we
have really low expectations like wow
that's interesting
let me noodle on that and then I think
Costa Rica's kind of squirrely in the
middle in a lot of respects
so stuff to ponder work on both and also
it just struck me that given all the
talk about stoicism and so on that I
tend to be people over the head with
stoicism in a lot of respects I would
view as a complete philosophical system
that checks a lot of boxes but it does
focus quite a bit on refining your
expectations and preparing for the
worst-case scenario so I often had quite
a healthy dose of epicureanism and so on
which is more on the opposite side
in any case Tim thank you so much and
we're gonna jump into some audience
questions I know
[Applause]
we will definitely be doing some
individual hellos but we jump in and see
what we have here and I suspect there
might be some curveballs slash bear
traps that I don't want to step into so
let me see what we have here bear with
all right you're 20 you have 3 to 6
months free job post to college all
right I take that to mean 3 to 6 months
after graduation to do whatever no
financial social commitments and you've
already read Tim's books all right thank
you for that how do you spend your time
to maximize well-being and develop
perspective
ahman from Paris well-being and
developed perspective three to six
months now you may have already done
this where's month money alright so you
may have already done this but if if I
were giving advice to the normal
American audience for that I would say
travel for those three to six months go
to countries where you do not speak the
language get deliberately lost in places
that are safe perhaps like Japan or
Costa Rica in most places and for
well-being in developing perspective
well-being would mean deliberately
exposing yourself to people who are
worse off maybe at least financially
than yourself so spending part of that
time volunteering for instance in this
three to six months and then that will
simultaneously help you to develop many
many different perspectives that would
be just as speaking as someone whose
life was changed completely by a number
of overseas experiences which I had
starting at age 16 or 17 I had never
really spent time outside of the u.s.
that would be my recommendation Tim give
any other any other thoughts so I think
that's right in line with what I would
have said which is basically traveling
to me is like and that is another way to
zoom out because you're just looking at
your life and far away you know it's
like you don't you're not going there to
look at your life but you end up
thinking about your life is for some
reason being far away being out of your
comfort zone and out of your element you
just have fresh eyes on your whole
situation you can have this perspective
you can kind of it's like going in a
helicopter and looking at it from up
there and a lot of things make sense and
then I would have also said couple that
with like kind of like a hard sue min on
like reality which is which I think you
get from I might have said like wait
tables were construction just do
something where you kind of like you're
just around working people and you just
I don't know it just it just just
reminds you what like work is like what
reality is like what adults you know go
through and then that can like help you
figure out where you're about to you
know where you're about to be in what
you want to do yeah for sure and the
travel advice I would not limit to
someone just getting in college I think
everybody when possible should to have
that experience because the benefits
outlast the trip because what'll happen
to most people especially if you put
yourself in very foreign environments
where perhaps you can't even read what
is written
Japan China many different examples
right whether it's Cyrillic Arabic
doesn't matter I and you observe
different customs what happened to me at
least in Japan for instance it's my
first real time abroad for a years in
exchange dude the only person who looks
like this in a school uniform in a high
school of 5000 Japanese kids right
pretty easy Where's Waldo game but as I
wait they drive on the other side of the
street that doesn't make any sense then
I was like wait a second maybe we don't
make any sense Oh what they take a
shower before they get into the bathtub
that doesn't make any second it makes
perfect sense and I got back and I
realized how many rules we follow are
just made up they're just totally made
up very fragile socially reinforced
illusions that we just reinforce and
that's very liberating cuz you realize
wait a minute like if all of these
different cultures do things differently
and maybe I don't have to go there to do
things differently
I can do that here then you start to
really question assumptions and you
become in my experience more
experimental alright let's go to another
question what trends industries topics
are you most excited about right now
Patrick Patrick Patrick here yeah hey
Patrick all right I like that height and
applies to both of us it simplifies
matters what trends industries topics
are my most excited about right now
speaking for myself friends I'm not
watching very closely
I have trouble explaining why really I
suppose I'm not trying to capitalize on
any trends because I feel like
particularly having left Silicon Valley
and having moved to Austin which I love
on almost every level if I am spotting
trends that I hope to capitalize on by
the time you see it you're too late
generally speaking so I'm not paying a
lot of attention to trends industries I
am interested just almost from an
academic standpoint in space travel not
so much from a personal experience
standpoint but specifically looking at
inhabiting planets versus building space
stations that debate is interesting to
me because you have some of the smartest
humans the last 1,500 years arguably
with very very different viewpoints and
whatever that happens in any field I'm
really interested you see that quite a
few places topics I would say and this
might be considered a trend I'm hoping
to turn it into a trend which would be
scientific research using current
cutting-edge technologies to re-examine
both the psychedelics and MDMA which I
wouldn't strictly consider
the traditional sense of psychedelic for
applications to very debilitating
serious conditions ranging from PTSD to
was this treatment resistant depression
end-of-life anxiety and so forth
so I've taken most of my energy and
capital that went into startups and
redirecting that to scientific research
at Johns Hopkins
hopefully other places like UCSF NYU
also that are taking these compounds
that have been used very very wisely I
think in certain contexts for millennia
by various civilizations and applying a
scientific lens to understand the
mechanisms of action and the risks
involved quite frankly but how they can
be less politicized and stigmatized for
unscientific reasons and examined so
that we have a better understanding of
why they do what they do which can be
pretty cool about you trends industries
topics that you're excited about right
now definitely some of those agree with
you on getting the stigma off of you
know perspective altering drugs but um I
would I would also had there's a lot of
cool things going on in what field that
also has a stigma called life extension
and the stigma is that it just seems
like it's like you know narcissistic
rich white guys who want to live forever
but the truth is it's and people think
it's vain and there's a narcissistic
kind of thing but really what you could
just reframe it as it's if you just cure
or learn how to manage like the four
things that kill people basically which
is like heart disease stroke Alzheimer's
cancer it just means that like and and
other things going on in health like we
can just live a lot longer and higher
quality later years like who doesn't
want that it's this like knee-jerk
reaction that makes people not even want
to put money your time into this
industry but like it's it's I just feel
like there were definitely people back
when humans lived on average to 40 you
know would have been like oh the deaths
at 40 is a lot of man like living to 80
or so but like now we're all happy about
that no one wants to go back so
if suddenly you know I don't know 140
140 was the new 90 and 90 was the new 50
like who's not happy about that like so
you know we say all because you know at
that point you're done well double lives
it cuz we got used to them we're
managing our own expectations if we all
died at 35 I would be like well it's
been good but like I'm not like that
I'm all ambitious and excited because I
think I have more decades so I think
that there's a lot going on Mark
Zuckerberg and his wife forgot to you
know one of them you know teams that are
trying to cure all diseases by the end
of the century like this is just a
machine and the diseases are just a
glitch inside of the Machine like if we
can have you know enough nanotech and
really fancy AI and you know medicine
you know and everything we can can go in
there and fix it this is a fantastic
development the most heartbreaking thing
is someone you know that you love dying
especially early let's work on that so I
think there's a lot going on there but I
think that a lot more would be going on
if the stigma of this is kind of like a
narcissistic pursuit would just go away
yeah to to comment on one thing there in
terms of the nurse assisting rich people
you everyone should want the
narcissistic millionaires and
billionaires to spend as much money as
possible on this right you want them to
be the people who create the economies
of scale for everybody else and many of
the things we take for granted now like
recycling started off being very
hoity-toity affluent experiments and you
you want them to be spending millions of
dollars on something that in ten years
is gonna be available for $50 a yes
again it's plumbing like in sanitation
these things are all rich you know rich
people things for a while and like then
everyone benefits tremendously from them
so like people also get mad they think
oh and this is well this is just gonna
benefit like the rich is this unfair
thing we're like super rich people will
be able to live like longer neck yeah
for a while and then it trickles to
everybody because the cost comes down as
we get better so like get over it you
know on that note
we got uh if you want to read some I
think very interesting thinking related
to what might account to life extension
or at least death prevention dr. Peter
Atia is one to pay attention to one of
my favorite people what is the name of
the city everyone must visit before they
die thanks for everything
Steve Steve Grill not to be confused
with Steve Carell this CA yeah it's a
great name
it's a great name spelled differently uh
on my list I would have to go with Tokyo
because it has such an unusual
combination of safety cleanliness
extreme weirdness and incomprehensible
'ti even to someone who speaks to have
and hey is that it provides a really
unites unique I think I just used that
twice and I'm gonna get [ __ ] from
friends who love to heckle me for using
modifiers on unique they're like no
there's no such things very unique like
okay alright I'm gonna say it again
just annoy them it's a very unique
opportunity to feel extreme discomfort
and confusion with elation with next to
no real harmful consequences simple I
think that provides an awesome learning
opportunity and just a fun trip so I
would say I would say Tokyo's very
holistic hey you still my answer again
just in Japan all summer innocent it's
another it's like going to another
planet and you're like oh how did how
did this civilization live and you're on
another planet that's how different it
is and just isolate Western culture has
like you know infiltrated so many places
and it just hasn't really there and they
just have done everything their own way
so you're like how was the cab door open
oh it opens by itself then I get in and
it closes by itself that's really cool
so I had to give a different answer I'll
say Hanoi Vietnam
just because crossing the street is just
crazy so there's like bytes
like motorbikes just a sea of them sea
of them going by and there's no
stoplights and it doesn't stop and what
you do is it walkers you just walk it's
like it's like Indiana Jones like
walking over the thing you you just walk
and you just and they figure it out and
it's unbelievable it's like you feel
like you're like God walking on water or
something where you just like you just
like walk out and nothing happens but
the thing you don't want to do is like
we have freaked out towards it like
stops because then then then you're
doing it something they can't anticipate
but you gotta try this on
steady well paced strides yeah confident
yes it's it the same there I didn't go
down there you spent some time that host
you know yeah go with the floor or else
you die good advice oh my goodness all
right that one would take us both
several hours knowing you're two of us I
apologize to the person whose name I
will not read
dear Tim that applies both of us
regarding two crappy pages per day I'll
explain what that means how do you
structure your days and weeks when you
are working on a book thanks Jean or
Jeannie I'm not sure to fee all right
I'll go with a response all right so the
two crappy pages per day for those who
don't know was advice that I received
regarding writing and working on a book
what she can be in my personal
experience a very daunting intimidating
task and I would get frozen for days or
weeks and I'd try to write something and
wouldn't be perfect and I throw it out
and a mentor of mine or an author I knew
said your quota should be too crappy
pages per day and he told me this story
about IBM and how they they demolished
the competition by exceeding every sales
quota every quarter and just absolutely
steamrolling everyone for a long time
and he asked me do you know why that is
I said no and he said because the quotas
were low and then people were
unintimidated to pick up the phone to
make the calls and you can do the same
thing with yourself with writing and you
do that by making your bar for a
successful day to crappy pages that's it
even if you throw them above that you
never use them you've won the day if you
have to crabby pleases and of course
over time there are days when you just
get your two crabby pages and they are
really truly terrible and then there are
other days where you overshoot you're in
the flow and you get 10 15 20 pages you
don't need so many of those to
eventually put together and what can
become a book until is structuring my
days and so on I'll be super super
specific here because the weeks and
months basically looked identical and
it's just copy and paste of this
particular day I realized for myself the
OEE benefit greatly given historical
predisposition to bipolar and all these
various things
that's just written in my code
it's a whole separate story but yeah
it's kind of laughable at how pretty
suppose my family is that writing your
sunshine is really important so I write
books generally during summer months and
my day involves getting up not super
early but for me it was respect
respectively early which your pain is a
9:00 a.m. 9:30 before the Sun is setting
and I wake up I meditate for 20 to 22
minutes should be typically transmittal
meditation or some type of guided
meditation then I jump in the water
because I'm on Lake Long Island I jump
in the water to wake up I might do a
little bit of swimming I hop out I
already have pages from the night before
that I want to edit I will edit during
the day but I do my pros generation at
night that's just when I have the best
output but I can edit do that grunt work
during the day I have printed out pages
and I will go into a sauna which
requires all sorts of trickery because
you start sweating on the pages but go
into a sauna and I will hand edit those
pages then I come out take a quick
shower I have a very small breakfast of
some time typically say macadamia nuts
some eggs very very small and I continue
to work very often at a treadmill desk
and the treadmill desk works during this
period of time at a very slow pace
because say in the case of tribe of
mentors I'm handling outreach and
editing I'm not going to do couple
drafts and Composition at the treadmill
desk I will work at the treadmill desk
this is literally the exact day and this
won't take hours to explain then around
say noon or 1:00 p.m. hop on a bike with
a researcher or someone that I have
hired to be with me in the same house at
all times why is this important I
realized that writing is very isolating
for me and it
it can catalyze a lot of negative mental
states and downward spirals because I
feel alone so I have someone physically
there even though we could probably do
the work remotely they have to be
optimistic which fortunately my
researcher is everything to him is
hand-clapping amazing really good
influence to have around so we both get
on a bike so you'll notice there are
there there's there little bursts of
physical exercise inserted in the day
get on bikes ride to this very mediocre
delhi and we have mediterranean wraps
every day for those interested it is
whole wheat tortilla with chicken hummus
tomato avocado added always extra cost
and we eat our mediterranean wraps and I
have unsweetened iced tea plus sparkling
water and we work there until say five
or six Sun starts to set jump on the
bikes
sometimes head to the bay jump in the
water again head home and then have a
snack work for an additional two or
three hours then go to dinner there are
two or three restaurants that we go to
that's it those are the rotations and
for all these restaurants I'll give a
protip
Jesus what a long answer that I said
wasn't gonna be long all right protip
for people who might want to do this now
it's late we're going out late we're
having dinner at nine o'clock a lot of
these kitchens closed at say 9:30 10:00
what does that mean staffs gonna be
[ __ ] pissed that we're coming in
right as the door is about to close and
I know this because I worked in service
jobs as Busboys and waiters and
restaurants forever I get it so here's
what you do if three restaurants you
know you're gonna be going to them for a
few weeks or a few months you go to the
same restaurant for dinner three nights
in a row and then the next restaurant
same place three nights in a row each
night you buy rounds of tequila over and
over again for every person who works in
restaurant front of house and back of
house really important these people will
now love you
and they will let you hang out for an
extra hour hour and a half this is
really key okay so we do this then we go
home not too much to keep up and we'll
continue to prepare things for the next
day go to bed around 1 a.m. say and then
it's Groundhog Day over and over again
that's it and there are very often I
would say every other day
some type of killable swings or exercise
that is done immediately before leaving
to dinner
it's just that day over and over and
over again yes I see yours dance from
yes Joanne
yeah Jeanne goddamnit sorry
oh yes yes yes so the important to
clarify a question doing work where we
have lunch yes there are outdoor picnic
tables and we will sit down and work
outside that's actually a fairly key
point we have to have a high tolerance
for mosquitoes and ticks because it's
eastern Long Island
so caveat emptor on the Lyme disease or
Tim over the year if you take the
opposite of that answer I think you're
sixteen our weight is like a amorphous
wad of self-loathing it's basically
someone asked me no really what do you
you know what do you need with your work
what do you know now it's like I need a
gnome that will follow me around and
like shock me if I'm not working and
like what I'm supposed to be working and
they were kind of like that's kind of
but um I uh yeah no no I mean I mean
this is where you're awesome at and what
I admire you for and well you can also
just to be clear have really regimented
well structured self-loathing just
supposed to make that clear I can do but
I was like trying to memorize that
answer because I want to like I think
for me the times when I am being
productive I find that it that two days
of the two minutes two pages a day thing
resonates with me because for me it's
like if I get it in my problem when I'm
not being productive is it I had this in
my head I'm behind on my stuff so I need
to work 14 hours I need 14 hours of
writing today and I have done those
crazy hours when there's like a crazy
panic in my life so I know I can so I
think I can go without the panic it
never happens and then six hours into
the day I've already blown it I've
already blown the day and you get
discouraged and then you start to
self-fulfilling prophecy yourself that
of course I'm gonna blow it I blew in
the last three days and then so if I do
the same thing I say I'm gonna write
three hours today and then I've had a
successful day it's amazing all the
positive like reward pathway feedback
that comes in from feeling like you
succeeded that day and then that night
you can go to bed on time because I
already succeeded today as opposed to
thinking no I can't go to bed now I
can't like let this be BL the whole day
I didn't and that can feed on himself
and something I try to remind myself is
like someone who is
three three hours of writing five days a
week but really focused like phone is
away like deep deep focus writing 15
hours a week like it's shocking how much
you can produce like add those weeks
together 40 weeks later you have a book
right the difference between the
prolific writer and the person the
self-loathing person who doesn't write
anything is one does 15 hours a week out
of their hundred and twelve waking hours
a week writing and the other one does
zero out of one hundred and twelve
waking hours so 1/7 versus 0/7 6/7 of
those two people's days and lives are
the same I mean it is some people know
people who can't put something together
that you have this daunting kind of
assumption that the prolific writers
fundamentally different they're just
they just have they're working
constantly all the time it doesn't have
to be that way but it's the consistency
it is the IBM thing that's a really
great way to have it's so true to I mean
most most most writers I know spend the
majority of their time inventing things
to do to avoid writing they're like but
my plants dying there's there's really
no way that I could possibly Winston
needs another massage yeah I mean this
is an unconstructive environment the
writing socking to be a high quality if
I don't polish my tennis shoes and so on
very very true all right this will be
the the last question and then we'll
move on to the next phase of this
evening what experiments questions
hypotheses are you wrestling with right
now how have they changed over your life
where do you think they'll take you now
we may not have a chance to hit every
aspect of this but let's start with what
experiments questions I pop the season
let's let's start with you tell [ __ ] so
nice having his answer get out my what
experiments questions or hypotheses are
you wrestling with right now and then
let's I'm just gonna abridge this and go
to
do you think they might take you well
it's a little like my last answer I am
trying to so my mind is structured as I
explained in the TED talk you mentioned
with there's that there's three
characters this is a rational
decision-maker who's like you should
probably work right now it's 10:00 a.m.
it's you know on a Wednesday very good
time to work then there's the the his
pets the instant gratification monkey
who died he has a different idea is a
different idea of what 10:00 a.m. on
Wednesday is good for and then there's a
two of them go back and forth and the
instant gratification monkey wins every
single time which leaves me what I call
the dark playground where I'm like not
working but I'm supposed to be and the
only thing the only thing that breaks
that cycle is the third character who
suddenly wakes up when a deadline gets
closer or there's some external pressure
that's the panic monster and the panic
monster freaks the monkey out the only
thing the monkeys scared of he runs away
and I can get my thing done and I'm
gonna die at 45 and when I'm trying to
learn how to do especially since I'm
about to start my first book next year
so I like you've done 52 books I need to
let us learn from this man is like you
know a book is too big a project you
can't just do that all at once it's like
it's like at some point you have to
learn how to have this internal
motivation and for me I'm like a you
know a caricature of myself but there's
a lot of people in this room who maybe
aren't classic racast inators but we're
not realizing if there's no kind of
deadline even if they're not and down to
the wire with the deadline the deadline
itself just being there is what makes
them do stuff and that's dangerous
because actually a lot of what's really
important in life is that kind of
important but not urgent stuff the stuff
that doesn't have a deadline seeing your
friends and family and not changing
careers improving yourself in the long
run so I think like this whole these
three characters thing applies to a lot
of people apply is very much to me so
what I'm working on is trying to just
really really working on having
productive days
with nothing in the external world
making me because a child is not good at
that and I'm trying to be less of a
child that's my that's my goal for the
next year yeah empathize oh yeah I do I
do I do I do
most we're ducted person in the history
of no I'm just really good at showing
like the high right the high right well
I got really super when I get tired this
is gonna give me also its trouble I
actually after spending like a year only
speaking Japanese when I get really
tired I start to mix up my cars in my
house I'm not [ __ ] you Wow do you
speak Japanese yeah that's so cool yeah
it's a cool language so the and just so
you guys know she's gonna die grass for
a second in Japanese they have Nadi do
they have a syllabary and the RL and D
sounds are kind of combined into one
thing that's why not aware of the
distinction they kind of got screwed
when God was handing out phonemes they
didn't get a lot of sounds it's really
hard for them to learn other languages
but every ripoff for them but I'm
showing the highlight reel of like a
very mediocre movie so I'm good at any
other creates the illusion that I'm just
knocking out productivity all day not
the case which is why would people like
can we follow you around for a day I'm
like no absolutely not absolutely not
because you just be like are you gonna
do something no man I'm like I found
some lint in the carpet and I need to
fix this not a good like Dances with
Wolves experience for the documentary
film guard all right so what experience
questions I bought these in my wrestling
one is right now I'm gonna make this
maybe a little soft around the edges
which is not my style
typically it's like hard analytical
quantitative but whatever so I've spent
the vast majority of my life at best
tolerating myself it's true I had had
some some really horrible experiences
early on that led me to just decide sort
of self love was for other people I
could be a really good instrument for
compa too
I could hone myself into an instrument
with a high pain tolerance to be really
good at certain things and that was
enough and then I could get my joy or
happiness wherever I found that from
observing other people long story
compact that fully but suffice to say
like I accepted a really low level of
self regard and was really really
unforgivingly
brew told myself I mean I I talked to
myself endlessly every day we're doing
with decades in a way that I would never
speak to another person and what I've
realized in the last few months actually
in particular is that if you want to
fully love other people and to make
other people feel loved you can't get
away with just tolerating yourself you
cannot and you have to learn how to
forgive yourself for a lot but more so
than that for me at least is to have
compassion for earlier versions of
yourself that you might view as cowardly
or ashamed or weak and I was introduced
to that through something relatively new
from me which is called meta Emmy TTA or
loving-kindness meditation it sounds
super woowoo and I mean the 20 year old
version Tim would just be vomiting on
his shoes right now hearing this like oh
my god really you're embarrassing us
stop it but it's been a really profound
shift in my perspective and realizing
that even if my only goal is not
necessarily to love myself but to do the
greatest good I can possibly do with my
small amount of time on this planet that
I have to put my own oxygen mask on
first and that's something that comes up
a lot in travel mentors Arianna
Huffington Sharon Salzberg it comes up
again and again and I just want
everybody to realize this is part of my
supposed new mission of sorts is for
people to realize that if you're feeling
damaged or
flawed and that leaves you to be
depressed and to have a really really
low amount of regard for yourself where
you're really aggressively brutal to
yourself that the first thing to realize
is that you are not alone in feeling
that and in fact like certainly not
everyone in this book but I would wager
and this is just speculation in most
cases but a very very high percentage
have incredible demons and are fighting
battles that we all know nothing about
but I mean really with some very very
dark periods so a is that you're not
alone and B is that you can actually let
go of and repair almost all if not all
of what you think you should just lock
away and forget so that I suppose would
be what I am wrestling with right now
and working on and trying to communicate
and there's some really concrete ways
you can go about it I would recommend
everybody certainly if any of that
resonates do yourself a favor
get a book called radical acceptance by
Tara brach terrible title fantastic book
give it a read I could have a huge
impact yeah I was a question about
psychedelics I would say that yes is my
tentative answer but I would not
recommend that anyone touch psychedelics
without professional supervision there
are legal ramifications to consider and
I would take it as seriously as you
would choosing a neurosurgeon to remove
a tumor that if miss operated on would
result in a fatality there's a lot of
people right now miss Simon that's about
it right now a lot of people are going
on Craigslist and finding neurosurgeons
my friends a shaman would just order
some stuff from the internet from China
for ayahuasca we're gonna do it in our
slow cooker that idea
bad bad bad idea so there are many tools
I don't think that's the only tool
meditation silent retreats which I'm not
ready to recommend because I do think
they can be extremely destabilizing
there are many many tools in the toolkit
but the point I want to make is there
are tools and you can start with
something that does not involve visiting
your ancestors and seeing flashing neon
crocodiles in your mind which could be
radical except inside so take a look
thank you guys very much a thank Tim hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday then that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
humm that's 4-hour workweek dot-com all
spelled out and just drop in your
you know and you will get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you enjoy
it
this episode is brought to you by
convertkit my go-to email service
provider I use them for everything if
you've ever wondered how professional
bloggers podcasters youtubers and so on
can build a platform they control and
get the word out about their best
content email is still the answer I
think it's all social social social but
one algorithm change oops
bait and switch and I only reach ten
percent of your audience that is why
I've doubled and tripled down on the
milk after reviewing many different
email service providers I ended up
selecting convertkit for email like 500
Friday which goes out to about a million
people now because convertkit delivers
on what matters most to me at least
easy-to-use systems split testing and
resending technology both very very
important high rates of deliverability
and great hands on customer service so
whether you run a business or simply
have say a serious blog convertkit has
integrations with more than 70 different
services just that anything you might
need including hosting sites like
WordPress e-commerce platform like
Shopify lead capture technology and
bounce exchange or sumo and many more
they also offer a visual automation
builder that makes it really easy to
deliver the right content to the right
people in your audience just when they
want it if you want a segment in
different ways there's a lot of people
do convert kit offers plans that adjust
to the size of your business
so it's good option whether you have a
thousand people or 1 million on your
list and certainly I am planning on
growing and growing and growing and I
don't like switching email servers
writers so I thought very carefully
about this before I selected it check it
out take a look at convertkit comma
forward slash Tim that's convert CEO and
BER tki t.com potage Tim and you can get
your first month for free I kick the
tires test it out that way give it a
shot make sure that it works for you
your business and
that goodness if you're like me I hope
you'll find that they get the job done
that's certainly been my experience
let's check it out again that's
convertkit comm forward slash Tim for a
free month of email services this
episode is brought to you by peloton and
I'd heard about peloton over and over
again but I ended up getting a peloton
bike in the whole system after I saw my
buddy Kevin Rose I've known forever some
of you know and he showed up at my gate
at my house a while back and he looked
fantastic I asked was dude you look
great what the hell have you been up to
he's always doing a weird diet or
another but it only lasts like a week or
two so he always with dresses to the
mean after like 75 beers and he said
I've been doing peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't worry about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio it's some type of commute etc
new classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and his Iying high-intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes
and I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and
everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select by music
duration and so on each peloton bike
includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or an
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's fo n e PE l OT o n one peloton
calm and enter the code Tim all caps TI
m at checkout to receive $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase now you might say back
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory categories so this
hundred dollars off is a very legit
hundred dollars off so if you want to
get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one peloton calm and
enter the code Tim again that's Oh any
ppl o t am calm and entered the go timet
checkout to receive $100 off any
accessories including the shoes that you
will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
[Applause]